of operations that are performed on the hardware as well as optimization in the layout of those Gates next we will
execute kuit runtime Primitives provide the interface to IBM Quantum Hardware that allows transpiled circuit to run
this step also includes using error suppression and mitigation techniques which can largely be abstracted away from the user lastly we postprocess in
this step the data from the quantum processor itself is processed providing the user with useful results on the original problem basically this step
encompasses any further analysis of the data that is acquired now we're ready to discuss the foundation of quantum
programs which are quantum circuits hopefully you're already familiar with Quantum circuits but in case you're not you might want to first check out lesson
three Quantum circuits which is a part of understanding Quantum information and computation linked below we're only
going to be giving a short refresher here now a Quantum circuit is a network of quantum Gates and measurements linked
by wires that represent the cubits Quantum circuits can be read like sheet music from left to right starting at
Time Zero which is all the way on the left virtual cubits meaning cubits that haven't yet been assigned to an actual
physical Cubit on a processor are listed in increasing order from top to bottom once we set up our circuit we can add
gates to it single Cubit Gates like this hadamar gate here affect only the Cubit whose wire it's placed on multiple Cubit
Gates like this cot affect two or more cubits linked by the gate here in this example the state of Cubit one changes
depending on what the state of Cubit zero is in after all of the gates are applied we can perform measurements
which cause the results to be written onto classical registers one particularly important characteristic of
a circuit is its depth the depth of the quantum circuit is the minimum number of layers of quantum Gates executed in
parallel required to complete the computation defined by the circuit to be clear Quantum Gates can be executed in
parallel or in other words at the exact same time whenever they don't have any cubits in common but if two or more
gates act on the same cubits then we can't perform them in parallel we're forced to perform them one after the other because Quantum Gates take time to
implement the depth of a circuit roughly corresponds to the amount of time needed for quantum computers to execute the
circuit so knowing the depth of a circuit is important for knowing that it can be used to run on a particular device or not it also will tell us if it
has a good chance of turning out an accurate result next let's move on to the selection of a Quantum processor IBM
has recently released a whole new Fleet of processors all having over 100 cubits and you can log on to quantum.com to see
which processors you have access to the processors are all named after birds for reasons and the different logos
represent different types of processors so for instance these ones represent Eagle processors and this icon is a
heron the name of the specific processors are also found at the top they're all named after cities but that
doesn't NE necessarily mean that the processor is physically located in that City those are just names Cubit count
eppg and kops are also factors that are all listed we'll go over each of these
cubits now this is pretty self-explanatory cubits is just the number of total cubits available to use on that sole Quantum processor or
qpu EPG stands for the errors per layered gate which measures the average gate process error in a layered chain of
100 cubits basically you want to be as small as possible kops stands for circuit layer operations per second and
it measures how many layers of a Quantum volume circuit which is a virtual circuit a qpu can execute per unit time
the higher the number the faster we can compute this is equivalent to what flops means in classical Computing now these
different metrics may be more or less important depending on the specific application area that you're interested in next let's discuss at a high level
mapping to Quantum circuits the first step is the mapping step which essentially answers the question how do
I translate my problem into a Quantum circuit that can be run on Quantum Hardware now there's no doubt about it
mapping is a hard problem and it's an active area of research sometimes just being able to take a computational
problem and come up with a sequence of quantum Gates that helps solve it is the hardest part there isn't a foolproof
method that guarantees success but there are recommended guidelines and examples of problems that we already know how to
map the first guideline is to let classical computers do whatever work that they are better at themselves tests
that are easy for classical computers probably won't benefit from a quantum computer quantum computers are for problems that are classically hard of
course if this is your very first time using kkit or a quantum computer don't worry about finding a problem that is computationally complex break it down
into smaller problems that you can learn to address before going straight to a utility scale project next translate the
outcomes for your problem that you want to measure or understand into an expectation value problem or a sampling
problem for most types of problems this essentially corresponds to calculating a cost function a cost function is a
problem specific function that defines the problem's goal as something to be minimized or maximized and they can be
used to see how well a trial state or solution is performing with respect to that goal
this notion can be applied to various applications in chemistry machine learning Finance optimization and so on
also keep in mind that the hardware that you're going to be using has a specific topology some cubits aren't connected
and some are and ultimately you'll need to map your problem to a circuit that represents this IBM Quantum processors
use what's called a heavy hex topology which essentially equates to Cubit Connections in a hexagonal lattice which
we'll get into more later in the course for now the most important thing to keep in mind is that this stage requires
practice you need to have a good understanding of not only your problem but also the quantum Hardware
capabilities and we'll go through a specific example and use case later on to see how these can be best
balanced now let's discuss how to optimize a circuit for the hardware that we've selected the overall goal of the
optimization step is to map all of the virtual cubits from our circuit to actual real cubits somewhere on the
topology of the processor the name of the game is to reduce errors as much as possible to do this we first need to
route and lay out our circuit efficiently first thing to keep in mind is that not all cubits are connected as
I've already said some are actually far away from one another on the chip so we need to reduce or eliminate longdistance
interactions whenever possible you can apply a sequence of swap Gates between neighboring cubits to move Cubit
information around but swap gates are costly and prone to errors so there may be better ways of doing this next layout